(bright music)
- James Peebles is one of the
world's foremost cosmologists.
For over 40 years, his research
and foresight have helped
to transform cosmology into a focused
and rapidly-advancing science.
Peebles laid the foundation
for many modern
cosmological investigations
by predicting the existence of
cosmic background radiation,
popularizing the notion of
dark matter in the universe,
and developing a theory
of how the universe evolved into galaxies.
He also pioneered statistical tests
to track and quantify the
motions of matter in the cosmos.
These tests necessitated the creation
of new computer-based simulations
to compare the competing
theoretical models
of Peebles and others.
Peebles continues to
study the related issues
of cosmological tests,
the nature of dark matter,
and the origin of the galaxies.
Peebles received his BS in 1958
from the University of Manitoba
and his PhD in physics from
Princeton University in 1962
and after spending three years
as a postdoctoral fellow,
he joined the faculty of the
Princeton Physics Department.
Peebles joined the Physics Department
where he's remained throughout his career.
In 1984, he became the
Albert Einstein Professor
of Science at Princeton.
Peebles retired from teaching in 2000
and continues to research the workings
of the universe as an emeritus professor.
Peebles' profound
contributions to astrophysics
and cosmology have been
recognized with numerous honors
including the Shaw Prize in Astronomy,
the Cosmology Prize of the
Peter Gruber Foundation,
the Gold Medal of the
Royal Astronomical Society,
and the Jansky Prize
of the National Radio
Astronomy Observatory.
Please join me in welcoming
Professor James Peebles.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you, a true pleasure to be here,
a place that I've always enjoyed visiting.
If you are of a certain age,
the odds are you're
recalling the stir caused
by the release of the first images
of Planet Earth from outer space.
A little surprising, perhaps,
that people should be stirred by it.
We knew then that the Earth is round,
clouds are white, the oceans are blue.
Yet knowing is different from
seeing and the experience
of seeing the Planet
Earth had a big effect,
I think, on our appreciation of the fact
that we live on a definitely
finite island universe
and it'd move us to take a
little bit better care of it.
So I propose to use the
tendency of so many of us
to be fascinated by images as
a vehicle in describing to you
what we know about the
universe in the large.
So let's get to work and remind ourselves
that the next planet out, Mars,
is not as photogenic as Planet Earth,
but certainly is a fascinating object.
We know that, for example, by
the work of Percival Lowell.
I introduce him because he'll
play an important part later
in my story this afternoon.
Perhaps you know the verse,
now we are in Boston, the
home of the bean and the cod,
where the Lowells speak only to Cabots
and the Cabots speak only to God.
This Percival was a Cabot.
He augmented his personal fortune
by work in the financial markets,
then indulged in his great
interest in many things.
First the Far East, then astronomy.
He's honored by astronomers
for his decision
to place his observatory in
an excellent site in Arizona
and to hire first-rate astronomers
to build instruments for it and use it.
Led to capital discoveries,
one of which I'll be mentioning later.
He tended to get a little
over-interested in Mars.
He thought he could see
all kinds of things on it.
In fact, he thought he could see evidence
of an active civilization
shaping the planet.
Well, he was a little
misled but he was right
in the general notion.
Surely if you looked at
Mars with a little care,
you'd see fascinating
new things, and indeed,
here is a close-up image
of the surface of Mars,
a river long since dried up
but won't it be fascinating
when we have a view
of what's left on the
sides of this old river?
The next planet out, Jupiter,
has the composition of the sun,
about 3/4 hydrogen, 1/4 helium,
and trace amounts of the
stuff out of which Mars
and the Earth are made.
It has weather.
The Great Red Spot has been there
for a couple hundred years,
a tropical storm of the sort
you see on the Weather Channel.
Now, we're not alone in our solar system.
Here is a tribute to Professor
Sarah Lee Lippincott,
based not far from Princeton,
an authority from the last
generation of the nearby stars,
and here are the models she made
showing the relative
positions of these stars
and their relative sizes and colors.
To my deep regret, I missed the chance
to take a photograph of this model
but we have a new generation
that are adept with computers
and they show us this picture
of the relative distributions
of the nearby stars.
Here's the sun.
The relative sizes are in proportion.
The relative position's in proportion,
but of course, the sizes of
the star is greatly magnified.
You see that there are
stars bigger than the sun.
Sirius here has twice the mass of the sun
and it's kinda hotter.
It has a companion that's quite faint
but very massive, a white dwarf,
the remnant of an exploding star
that's lost most of its nuclear fuel.
You notice that most of
the stars are less massive
than the sun, redder, a lot less luminous.
On a star-by-star basis,
the sun is pretty big.
The grid you may be able
to see is kinda cute.
For example, I can go to the right
along the plane of the board.
Go into the board and down
and I get Epsilon Eridani
which attracts our attention a little bit
because, according to a local expert
carrying on from Professor
Sarah Lee Lippincott,
Geoff Marcy on the left assures us
that that star I was just pointing to
very likely has a real planet,
another Jupiter, another solar system.
We're not alone, there are
other planetary systems.
It's gonna be fun to explore them.
Some stars reach the end of
their supply of nuclear fuel
on the edge of the universe, explode.
This is one mode of explosion.
It just blows itself apart in a supernova.
It scatters about the products
of the nuclear burning
of fuel to make energy to
shine, to radiate starlight.
This nuclear waste collects in clouds
and makes the clouds of hydrogen mostly,
polluted heavily with grains.
The grains make the clouds dark.
New stars form out of these gas clouds.
You can see that in this example,
the bright young stars are
on the far side of the cloud.
You can see the light
from the star is glinting
off the gas clouds but you
can't see the stars directly.
There's too much dust, it
blocks out the starlight.
That's an important effect in looking
at our galaxy of stars as a whole.
Here's a picture of the whole sky.
Many photographs, taken at night always,
of course, as we move around the sun,
and then the results stitched together
to make a map of the whole sky,
distorted on the edges greatly, of course,
because we're taking a sphere
and projecting it onto a plane
but you can see the general idea.
A band of light running
across the sky, the Milky Way.
You see rifts running through the band.
That's not absence of
stars but rather presence
of this absorbing dust,
and what we are seeing
is that we live in a disc of stars.
There are stars out of the disc
but most of them are in this disc
and we're seeing the
integrated light of the stars
running across the sky
from this disc of stars.
It looks from this picture as
if we're close to the center
of the disc because there
are about as many stars
in each direction seen,
but that's an artifact
of the absorption by dust.
This is a better image of
where we are in our galaxy.
Again, an all-sky picture but now taken
at wavelengths slightly
longer than what we can see.
At longer wavelengths, the
dust is much less absorbing
and so we get a much clearer picture
of where the stars are
in this Milky Way galaxy.
You see several important things.
You see the disc of stars,
you see a bulge near
the center of old stars,
and then you see that we are
distinctly in the suburbs
of this island universe.
We are not alone.
There are other galaxies of stars.
Here's one very much like
our Milky Way galaxy.
You see a bulge of old
stars, a disc of stars.
You see rifts running through
the disc, that's gas again,
polluted by heavy elements
that blocks the starlight.
There are several varieties
of these galaxies of stars.
Here is another one with a
much bigger bulge of old stars
and just a trace of
relatively young stars,
gas and dust in this disc.
A beautiful image from the
Hubble Space Telescope,
a magnificent instrument whose
existence depends these days
upon support from people like you
who let their congresspeople
know they would be ridiculous
to turn off this magnificent instrument
that gives us these gorgeous
images of the world around us.
I hope you agree.
(audience applauds)
(James laughs)
Don't applaud me, applaud
your congresspeople.
Other galaxies have no
disc, they're all bulge.
These galaxies don't sit in isolation.
They tend to appear in groups.
On the left, you see a
picture of three galaxies.
It's a negative so where
there is starlight, it's dark,
a big disc and then two smaller
and more irregularly-shaped galaxies.
There's a lot of hydrogen in
this concentration of galaxies.
The hydrogen emits radio radiation
at 21 centimeters wavelength.
A radio telescope can
detect that radiation
and give us a picture of this system
at a different wavelength giving
us a different impression.
If you had eyes sensitive
to 21 centimeters,
and you have very good eyes,
you would see the right-hand image
and you would ask yourself,
now, wait, is this one galaxy?
Notice the swirl of spiral arms running
from one to the other.
The definition galaxy is a
touch arbitrary, I would submit.
You see another example
of that in the next image.
Here is a plot of the galaxies
in one region of the sky
and at one range of distances from us.
You notice a tight concentration
of galaxies in the center
and then dribbling off to
lower and lower densities.
It's just like the distribution of stars
in that galaxy I showed
you that is all bulge,
a cusp in the center
and then the distribution
flaring out on the sides.
It's a galaxy of galaxies, which is neat.
Here is a picture of
that galaxy of galaxies.
It's dead in the center of this plot.
This shows the distribution
across about 100 degrees
of the sky looking up away
from the disk of our galaxy
where obscuration by dust
is not too important,
showing you the texture of our universe.
That's the large-scale
nature of our universe.
Here is the astronomer Donald Shane
who took the data to make that image.
These are then graduate students Jim Fry,
Ray Soneira, Mike Seldner,
and Bernie was offscreen,
maybe he wasn't even in my office
when this photograph was taken,
who took Donald Shane's data
and turned them into a map.
Shane with his colleague Carl Wirtanen
counted the galaxies one by one
with a traveling microscope in the 1950s.
It took them a decade,
one by one with a traveling microscope,
picking out the galaxies,
making a pile of data sheets shown here.
This is a set of copies in my office.
Think of them, think of the effort,
and then think of the
fact that in those days,
there's not a lot you can
do with a million numbers.
High-speed computers came along.
We could take his data, which
was taken with such care.
Then we could make this
image and show it to him
and asked him, so, is
this what you were seeing?
(audience laughs)
And have the pleasure
of him laughing at us
and saying, I was looking at
this one galaxy at a time.
This is the texture of
our universe in the large,
but we can go to bigger scales.
Let's not hesitate to
step back another step.
Oh, I should've remembered
to tell you that,
of course, data improves.
This is a modern version
of what you've just seen
called the 2MASS Survey,
Tom Jarrett and colleagues.
Again, photographed the whole
sky, but now used computers
to identify the galaxies and plot 'em up.
It's at about the same limiting distance
and you see the same texture.
This is the texture of our universe.
You see running through this image
of the whole sky a darkish band.
That's dust in our galaxy
and and in this projection
of the whole sky, the
plane of the Milky Way
is running in this S-shaped curve.
You should ignore that and
you should trust the rest.
This is the way we look.
But let's look at still further,
let's look on a still larger scale
and we can do that by
noticing that some galaxies
such as this one have
in the center, in fact,
all the big galaxies have in their center
a massive compact object
that the odds are very
strong is a big black hole.
The main operative thing
about a big black hole
is the strong gravity as you get close
and it tends to squeeze
things as they fall in.
It makes an explosion of this sort.
That is the center of that galaxy
and this Hubble Space Telescope
image shows you a lovely jet
of light running away from the center.
What's happening in very
rough terms is illustrated
by the consideration, what
happens if you take a tube
of toothpaste in your
hand and hold it firmly
and then you're startled,
very much startled,
you squeeze impulsively
that tube of toothpaste
and you make a jet, where is it?
Here it is, an experimental
demonstration of a jet
produced by compacting,
strongly compressing material.
In galaxies, this compression
is sometimes so violent
that it makes a jet of material
that is very much bigger than the galaxy
and that it produces radio radiation.
Here, an image from the Very Large Array
in Socorro, New Mexico, an
array of radio telescopes
with superb image-making qualities.
Isn't it a delight to see this?
Eyes that are as big as, well,
a couple of miles across,
sensitive to light, seven
centimeters wavelength,
and what do you see?
A jet riding on one side.
Alternately, I think,
one side or the other,
great blobs of plasma,
wisps of dense plasma nearby
and hotspots on the end.
A really wonderful thing.
An exploding galaxy left us this marker.
This doesn't happen very often in galaxies
and when it happens, it can
be seen at great distance,
and so by mapping out the
distribution of these galaxies,
we can get a really large-scale picture
of what's going on in the
universe and this is what you see.
This is a distribution across half the sky
of those exploding
galaxies, the brightest,
the nearest 20,000 or so, give or take.
Now, you should be careful.
The hole in the center is just,
the instrument couldn't point up there
and the hole down here, it's
in the interference by the sun.
The plane of the Milky Way in this map
runs along here like so.
This is a very bright
source in the Milky Way.
It's not another galaxy,
but it's bright enough
to confuse the instruments
so you should ignore, please, this region.
You should ignore the concentrations
of sources along here, and
ask yourself, what do you see?
Well, it's even duller than Mars.
You don't see anything, and
isn't that a remarkable thing?
You pause to consider
that in physical science,
we study sections from a
hierarchy of structures.
There are cells that contain atoms.
The cells are made into arms and legs.
Arms and legs are made into people
who are made into communities
that live on the Planet Earth
that's part of the solar system
that's part of the galaxy
that is part of a
supercluster of galaxies.
Level upon level of
structure and then it stops.
Isn't that remarkable?
And of course, this remarkable effect
is what makes possible for us to say
we're making a theory of the
structure of the universe.
We're not just taking a section
of a hierarchy of things
within things within things.
We've come to the end of the hierarchy
and we can study the behavior
of this end of the hierarchy
because, as you see,
it's wonderfully simple.
Quite an advance, quite
a conceptual advance
to see the end of structure.
You understand that within this map,
there is all that clustering of things
that you've seen illustrated earlier,
but because the objects here are so rare
and we are looking over
such a range of distances,
we lose all that clustering.
We see only the large-scale pattern
and what we see is uniformity.
That is the first law of cosmology.
Let's go on to the second law.
Oh no, I forgot to say,
it's fun to look at the telescopes
that produce some of these images.
This is the great 300-foot telescope
in West Virginia on which
those data were taken
and this is the great 300-foot telescope
in West Virginia as the
project was completed.
It fell down.
(audience laughs)
It's all right, no one was hurt,
and the senior senator from West Virginia
was not about to see the
great state of West Virginia
lose a major scientific instrument
and so somehow funds were found
to build this elegant, new,
much more powerful Robert
C. Byrd Green Bank Telescope
(audience member laughs)
based in West Virginia.
I don't quite know what to think of this
but I come up with the conclusion
that it's only pork if
you're not at the trough.
(audience laughs)
It's a magnificent instrument for science.
How can I complain?
As a taxpayer.
There it is now, to emphasize it.
We have something simple
that even a scientist can deal with.
And I come back to Percival
Lowell who, as I said,
earned the deep respect of astronomers
by his decision to do great science
by hiring great astronomers to do it.
One of them, Slipher, built the instrument
and used it to detect
the spectrum of light,
intensity of light at each
wavelength coming from a galaxy,
showing first that the light
from galaxies is just
starlight, bunch of stars,
and second, that in distant galaxies,
the light is shifted towards the red.
The effect, proposed then and
now we know to be the case,
is the Doppler shift which
you're all familiar with
if you've stood by the side of the road
and noticed the noise
coming from a passing car.
The noise of the motor says bu-room.
The pitch of the motor isn't
changing as the car roars by,
but as the car is approaching you,
the wavelength of light
is pushed together.
That makes the pitch go up.
As the car is moving away from you,
the motion stretches the wavelength.
The pitch goes down, bu-room.
So it is with light.
He, Slipher, demonstrated that the light
from distant galaxies is
shifted toward the red
as if they were moving away from us.
We now interpret that, I
believe, entirely correctly
as the effect of the expansion
of this uniform universe.
It was a deep puzzle
at the time he found it
and this person, Georges
Lemaitre, Belgian,
in 1923, shown here,
a few years later gave
the now accepted explanation,
the expanding universe.
In this year, he discovered
not only a great love of God.
He's Roman Catholic, was,
but also of general relativity theory,
the theory Einstein had invented
for a better theory of gravity,
one that is now very thoroughly tested.
In those days it was just a theory,
but people were looking
very hard for applications
and Lemaitre found one.
Here are some key players in
the next part of the story.
Einstein, as I said, invented
general relativity theory
that Lemaitre was soon to use.
This person, Dutch, Willem
de Sitter, will appear
in a moment but try to remember his face.
The hair is moved from
here to here, and finally,
the professor of astronomy
at Cambridge University
in England, Arthur Stanley Eddington.
Lemaitre decided to expand his knowledge
of general relativity by
studying first at Cambridge
and here we have evidence of it
from a letter from Eddington.
I certify that Abbe George Lemaitre
has been attending my lectures
and pursuing his studies
and investigations to
my entire satisfaction
during the academic year 1923, 1924.
From there, Lemaitre went
to MIT, the other Cambridge,
Cambridge, Massachusetts,
where he continued his studies
in general relativity theory
and he attended a talk
by this astronomer, Edwin Hubble.
I'll talk later today and again tomorrow
about this instrument and about
this person, Richard Talman.
He heard from Hubble
about Hubble's studies
of Slipher's effect and
about the curious pattern
that Hubble was finding that
the more distant the galaxy,
the more rapid the red shift,
the more rapid the recession
velocity of the galaxy.
It was that lecture by
Hubble that inspired Lemaitre
to invent the theory of
the expanding universe.
Here again, I don't remember
why I showed you twice
but here is, we have evidence,
so now let me tell you the story
because it is somewhat educational.
Lemaitre wrote his paper on
the expanding universe in 1927
but he published it in
Dutch in a Belgian journal
that the in crowd did not read.
He waited patiently for a
response from the in crowd,
what do you think of my idea?
Got none.
He wrote to Eddington, whoops,
reminded him of his acquaintance
and said what do you think of my work?
No response, not until a second
letter several years later,
but was it a response?
And it was not a very vigorous one.
Eddington wrote to de Sitter.
Here again is de Sitter
and here is the letter
Eddington wrote to de Sitter.
Here is the date, 1930,
and here is an interesting message first.
Lemaitre's address in Leuven in Belgium.
Then a comment, a research student,
George McVittie and I had
been worrying at the problem
and made considerable progress,
so it was a blow to us to find
it done much more completely
by Lemaitre, a blow softened
as far as I am concerned
by the fact that Lemaitre
was a student of mine.
Well, you learn from this first
that if you do something
great, you will win friends,
but we have to admire Eddington
for his decision immediately
to arrange to have
Lemaitre's article reprinted
in a prominent journal of astronomy.
He made Lemaitre famous.
You can tell he was famous
because here is de Sitter,
a caricature in, following
an interview by him, of him,
published in a prominent
newspaper in the Netherlands.
The bottom part of the figure,
I will be discussing tomorrow.
The top part, I hope you will agree,
is a pretty good caricature
of the great Professor
Dr. Willem de Sitter
and here is an analog showing
de Sitter's explanation
to the newspaper of what
Lemaitre had in mind
by this notion of expanding universe.
Pretend that you live not in
three dimensions but in two.
Pretend that you're an ant that may crawl
along the surface of this balloon.
You notice it's kind
of a neat arrangement.
This world the ant lives in is finite.
The ant may start in a given direction
and move in a straight line.
It'll end up back where it started from,
no boundaries to this universe,
no edge, it's homogenous,
uniform everywhere, but it's finite.
You might ask me, so, what about the space
off the balloon inside and outside?
I tell you, don't ask that question.
You live in two dimensions,
you live on the surface of that balloon.
One other cautionary
note, stars and galaxies
are more or less sketched on this balloon.
The stars and galaxies aren't expanding.
You have to think of those as
little pieces of paper perhaps
attached to the balloon in one spot.
But now the really neat thing.
You are living on one of these
galaxies and you look around
and what do you see as
the balloon is blown up?
You see the nearby galaxies
moving away from you
and you see further galaxies
moving away from you fast.
That's just the pattern that
Hubble had been discovering
for an expanding universe.
That was a great connection
that made everyone so excited in 1930.
Now, of course it's one thing to say
this fits the observations,
uniformity, the redshift,
the apparent Doppler shift,
an expanding universe,
but how do I know that's
the way it really is?
You know that the way, you test that
by finding other effects, other checks,
other experimental
conditions that are required
to fit by the same theory
of an expanding universe.
It was Lemaitre, in fact, who realized
that there ought to be further evidence
of this expanding universe theory,
that if the universe did start expanding
in this very different state,
surely it left fossil evidence
of the very different state.
He writes in this photograph,
this is a photograph of Einstein.
He writes, the evolution of
the world can be compared
to a display of fireworks
that has just ended.
Some few red wisps, sashes and smoke
standing on a well-chilled cinder.
We see the slow fadings of the suns
and we will try to recall
the vanished brilliance
of the origin of the worlds.
Let's find the vanished brilliance.
Let's find fossils of that time
when the universe was so very different.
The person who showed us
how to interpret the fossil we
have found is Richard Talman,
professor of physics
at Caltech in Pasadena
who developed the theory of heat radiation
in an expanding universe.
Heat radiation, you've all experienced.
Stand by a fire and put out your hand.
You're feeling radiation,
that's heat radiation.
It has an important
property in a closed vessel.
If I keep the walls at
a definite temperature
and let things relax to equilibrium,
then the vessel will be
filled with radiation,
black-body radiation, often
called thermal radiation,
with the property that you
tell me the temperature
and I'll tell you the intensity
of that radiation at each wavelength.
What Talman shows is in
an expanding universe,
this radiation doesn't go away.
There's no place for it to go,
but it is cooled by the
expansion of the universe
and the really important thing
is it maintains its
thermal black-body spectrum
and so a fossil from this early time,
if the universe was hot to begin with,
would be the remnant thermal radiation
and we would know it's
thermal by its spectrum.
This was used after the
end of the Second World War
by George Gamow, a great
astronomer of a previous generation
with his student, Ralph
Alpher, and a few others
to make a theory of the
origin of the elements.
In fact, it is now our standard theory
for the origin of helium.
Most of it was cooked in the hot Big Bang.
I won't get into that detail today,
but just to remind you of this photograph,
maybe some of you remember living
under the threat of nuclear war
and this Herblock image of, well,
this of the hydrogen bomb and
the caption, five minutes, eh?
For scientists says world
was created in five minutes.
Well, that's the first five minutes
of the expanding universe.
Here is a photograph of a
temporary building at MIT
built during the Second
World War for war research.
Here is a professor of
astronomy at MIT, Ray Weiss,
pointing toward this temporary building
built during the war,
torn down only recently,
and, to my mind, a sad event.
There ought to be things
preserved from old times,
but here is a photograph of
my thesis advisor, Bob Dicke,
on top of that rooftop
with one of his inventions,
a microwave radiometer.
I'll explain now what
this radiometer does.
Here is a sketch of the skyline
of Cambridge from that rooftop.
In those days, Cambridge had factories.
Some of the factories had chimneys
and some of the chimneys were warm.
Up above is a chart recorder
showing the response
of his microwave radiometer
as it was swung across the sky
and swung past those chimneys.
You see what's happening.
As the different lines or different angles
down from the vertical,
as the radiometer is
swung across the horizon,
it shows a deflection
at each warm chimney.
This is just the device to
detect thermal radiation.
This is a photograph of Bob Dicke
about 25 year later on the left,
Jer Yu, my first graduate student
whose role will appear
in tomorrow's lecture,
and David Wilkinson, a long-time friend
and close colleague of
Princeton University.
Slightly before this photograph,
Bob had the idea that one ought to look
for this fossil radiation
from a hot early universe
and he persuaded David Wilkinson
to build a Dicke
radiometer for the purpose
of looking for this radiation.
Here is Dave in working clothes.
He's holding, if you
can see, a screwdriver.
Behind here is his colleague,
perhaps you can see the sleeve
of his plaid shirt, Peter Roll.
They build this radiometer to look
for that thermal radiation
that would be present
if the universe started hot and expanded
from a dense hot state.
Here is a telescope at Bell Labs,
a mere 30 miles or so from Princeton,
that was used in early experiments
with satellite communication.
First, bouncing signals off a big balloon
in orbit back down to Earth.
Then later, a satellite that would receive
television signals from the ground,
transmit them back down to the ground.
Early efforts in long-range communication.
This telescope had a curious problem
that vexed very much Bob
Wilson and Arno Penzias
who wanted to use this
telescope for radio astronomy.
It was detecting too much radiation.
They were at their wits' end
with this curious feature
of this radiometer
when Bernie Burke, here in the center,
who knew both groups, told the
two groups to get together,
the one looking for the radiation,
the other with the radiation
but not knowing what to do with it.
(audience laughs)
Bernie was at MIT, it's curious
how these things happen.
1925, Lemaitre is at MIT.
1945, Bob Dicke is at
MIT building a radiometer
while Lemaitre's country
is being torn apart
by the Second World War.
1965, he's bringing, at MIT,
the two groups together.
Things work in curious ways.
Here is the situation.
Penzias and Wilson at seven
centimeters wavelength
had radiation coming in from
all directions equally strong
that they didn't know what to do with.
Here, shortly after the two groups met,
the Princeton experiment was completed.
It detected radiation here.
This is the curve of
intensity at each wavelength
you would expect if this
radiation is thermal,
black-body, left over
from the early universe,
if it's a fossil, and you see,
it already looked pretty good.
The story of much of cosmology
for the next several decades
was the work in filling
in this part of the curve
and checking does this
radiation really follow
the prediction you would expect
if this is thermal radiation left over
from the hot early universe?
A lot of work was done in that direction
but I will immediately
go to the experiment
that solved the problem.
It had to be done above
the Earth's atmosphere
because at wavelengths near the peak,
the atmosphere is strongly
absorbing and emitting.
It just totally makes the
experiment impossible.
You have to get above the atmosphere.
Here is a proposal to NASA for a satellite
that became known as COBE,
Cosmic Background Explorer.
The proposal was made by John Mather.
Here's Dave Wilkinson.
One of the PIs was Mike Hauser
who made this image I showed earlier.
The other was George Smoot who
I will be roasting tomorrow.
It's interesting that Mather
was, at the time, a postdoc
and he was proposing to bet his career
on a satellite whose design
started in the mid '70s
and was flown in 1990.
Imagine it, the work required,
and during that time,
he was not accumulating a
track record of research.
He was concentrating on
one big basket of eggs
that could, on launch, break.
He is made of stern stuff
for which he earned this year's
Nobel Prize in connection
with another person who
will be discussed tomorrow.
Here is a photograph of the COBE group.
Here you see George Smoot,
you see Mike Hauser,
Mike Hauser who made that
beautiful picture of our galaxy,
here you see David Wilkinson,
and here, John Mather,
and here, the result of this experiment.
I gotta explain this in a little detail
'cause it's kinda confusing.
The thin line is the theory.
This is what it oughta look like.
The thick line is the measurement
under which is the theory, of course.
The other symbols are
discrete measurements made
by other groups and you see something
that is absolutely gorgeous,
a dead close fit of
theory and observation.
This is the smoking gun.
This radiation could not be produced
in the universe as it is now.
We know that because the
universe is transparent.
It's not a black body.
We know it's transparent
because we can see
those distant radio galaxies
that I was describing earlier.
This radiation is traveling
freely from where?
From the early stages of the hot universe.
Here is tangible evidence,
just like dinosaur footprints convince us
those improbable looking
creatures did walk the face
of the Earth, so this tells us
that our universe did expand
from a hot, dense state.
What an advance, truly amazing.
Well, I can't let this moment
pass without reminding you
that there is a competition
in any measurement in science.
Here is Herb Gush who during
the time from the mid '70s
to 1990 was working on his own experiment,
this one to be a rocket rather
than satellite experiment,
to measure this radiation.
It's not a very good picture
but I think you can see
this guy exudes confidence.
He is a solid person.
Here are his two associates
in the experiment that worked,
Mark Halpern on the left,
Ed Wishnow on the right.
You can see it's a terrible reproduction
but it's one of my favorite
images from astronomy.
I just love it because you
look at that, I ask myself,
if I didn't know these guys
had done something great,
if I only had this image to judge them by,
would this image inspire confidence?
(audience laughs)
I just can't resist another verse,
you see that I'm a very poetical person,
another verse about Barbara Frietchie
who you remember during the
Revolutionary War saying,
shoot if you must this old gray head,
but spare your country's flag,
and then I have in mind Ogden
Nash's take on the situation.
I always admired Barbara Frietchie.
I bet she scratched when she was itchy.
(audience laughs)
Great science is done by
committed, capable people
like these two, but first of all,
great science is done
by people who scratch
when they're itchy like the rest of us.
Well, here it is, tangible evidence
that our universe is
understandable, in a way.
It has an evolution, it has a
history, and a surprising one.
It began hot and dense and expanded
to the present time leaving a fossil.
Like any other fossil, this plot one
has interesting clues built into it
that I will be discussing tomorrow,
but I think this is a good
place to start winding down
and I've decided that because
there are some questions
that I receive time after
time giving this talk,
I thought I would review them now
ahead of general discussion.
So here is my list of the four
most frequently-asked questions
in my experience on this subject.
So, the first question.
You claim our universe expanded
from some dense hot state.
So what was our universe
like before the Big Bang?
Well, of course, people
have worried about this.
There are very attractive ideas
on what the universe was
doing before it was expanding
but the solid part of our subject,
where we have the experimental evidence
is in the evolution from the
dense state to the present.
Don't ask us to do everything.
We're gonna leave some science
for the next generation.
The part that is solid is at expansion
from high density to the present.
So, next question.
So can you at least say
where this Big Bang happened?
Can you point to the place in the sky?
Hello.
(audience laughs)
Didn't you see that map
of the radio galaxies?
Didn't you see how uniform it is?
There's no edge that we
can see to the universe.
The universe is everywhere
and it's expanding everywhere.
There's no center.
Why do you keep avoiding
the term Big Bang?
Because it's so misleading.
A bang to me connotes an event,
but I just tried to tell you,
we don't have a theory for that event,
what happened as the
universe started expanding.
What we know, and have
tested well, I think,
as I'll describe in more detail tomorrow,
is that the universe has
expanded from this dense state,
hot, to the present.
What is more, a bang connotes a location.
It exploded right, there's
where the bomb was,
but there's no location
in the expanding universe.
It's everywhere, expanding
at almost the same rate everywhere.
If you're so smart,
(audience laughs)
this is something I've often asked myself.
In the connection of
research and cosmology,
my answer is we're pretty smart.
We've made some striking advances.
I've shown you one, I'm gonna
describe some more tomorrow.
We're not all that smart because
there are lots of questions
you can ask me that I can't answer.
Tomorrow I'm going to describe
some of these deep puzzles
which I am going to put
a very positive spin on,
saying we're leaving lots of work,
lots of fascinating work to be
done by the next generation.
We're not that smart, but
we are making progress.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- [William] Professor
Peebles has agreed to respond
to questions from the audience.
Are there any?
- [Man] Thank you for the four questions
and part of that is some
of the data that you have
and put in two-dimensional play comes back
and with the redshift indicates
that it's three-dimensional.
My question is has anybody made a model
of what the universe was like
when those earliest
photons first reached us,
or on the opposite side,
now that they've traveled
all those billions of years,
where are they now projected to be now
when we finally get the information?
- This gets complicated, doesn't it?
- [Man] Yes.
- The galaxies are moving away from us
as if we were at the
center of the Big Bang,
isn't that right?
But yet, in this theory, if
you go to a distant galaxy,
you will see the galaxies
around you moving away.
You'll even see us moving away from you
as if you were at the
center of the explosion.
The central thesis of this
first law of cosmology
is that the universe is
uniform, the same everywhere,
aside from local deviations,
local clustering.
You may say this radiation
that is streaming toward us
came from somewhere.
Indeed, it did, but it wasn't aimed at us.
Go to a different place, you'll
see radiation hitting you.
Wherever you are, the
radiation is streaming by.
One could ask where is
that radiation going?
It's traveling through the universe.
It's not being lost.
Each photon is conserved,
apart from the few that
hit dust and get absorbed.
They rearrange themselves,
keeping uniform or close to uniform
in this expanding
universe without an edge.
I don't know if that's comfort
but the best I can do.
- [Man] Well, I've a very simple question.
I'd like to know, in your
opinion, if the universe,
like a balloon, is bounded,
unbounded and finite,
or is it unbounded and infinite?
- I'll be discussing some
aspects of this tomorrow.
The evidence is that the balloon model
is a little misleading.
The evidence is that space is not curved
in the nature of a balloon
but rather flat in our
three spatial dimensions.
Space time is curved to be sure,
but a space section is flat,
not curved inward or outward.
I use the balloon analogy
because to me, it's visual.
I can see it, if you see what I mean,
but the evidence, as I
say, is that space is flat.
I can't tell you that space is infinite
because the universe is only
about 14,000 million years old.
During that time, light has
traveled a finite distance.
We can't see beyond that.
We can't check that the universe extends
arbitrarily far beyond the
section we can see, and in fact,
popular ideas about what
the universe was doing
before it was expanding would project
that we're in a section of universe
that's enormous but finite,
outside of which there's a terrible mess
that we won't think about.
- [Man] Is there any independent evidence
aside from redshift that
would give a signature showing
that the early universe was
more compact, more dense,
such as, let's say, gamma ray burst.
Is there some signature,
some empiric evidence to show
that with increasing
deep time observation,
there's a higher compaction
of the superclusters
and clusters of galaxies?
- Yes, excellent question,
give me more evidence.
I promise tomorrow to
offer some more evidence.
The more pieces of evidence
we have, of course,
the tighter the story, the
better the cross-checks,
the more believable is the picture.
I feel confident now that we
have the tangible evidence.
It always is indirect, of course.
We can't travel in a time
machine back in time.
We can instead only look at the clues
that nature offers us and
interpret them and find,
once we have an interpretation,
whether new clues as they come
in fit the interpretation.
The more clues that fit,
the more confident we are.
I'll describe tomorrow some of the clues
that convince me that
we're on the right track
while at the same time leaving
open some very deep puzzles.
- [Man] You told us some
very interesting history
about one paper that got hidden in Dutch.
Could you tell us a little
bit about what happened
with Gamow's paper, why people
didn't know much about it?
- (laughs) That is another
very interesting story.
Gamow had many of the
ideas of the now standard
hot Big Bang, if I may use
that phrase, back in the 1940s
including a now well-tested theory
for the origin of the light
elements, deuterium and helium,
including the hot radiation
that should be detectable now
by instruments we have.
That was written at about the same time
that Bob Dicke invented the radiometer
that I showed you illustrated
and that was capable of
detecting that radiation.
The two groups never got together
and by the time Bob Dicke
in the mid 1960s persuaded
David Wilkinson and Peter Roll
to build one of his radiometers
to look for this radiation,
that paper of Gamow, that
set of papers of Gamow
had been pretty well lost to sight.
When I started working in this
field in 1964 approximately,
I knew nothing of Gamow.
I knew nothing of that early work.
I discovered that much of my early work
was in fact reinventing Gamow's wheel.
We got together, we got the
whole story by about 1970
but there was a time of great confusion
when we didn't realize
what had been done earlier
and what hadn't.
Maybe you're aware that
that left Gamow very better.
He felt he wasn't thoroughly recognized
for his accomplishments
and that might've been so.
I hope we got the record
straight before his death though.
- [Man] The most popular
model for the evolution
of the universe has it
proceeding from a singularity
and going through an era of inflation.
Another model has a collision of membranes
in a hyperspatial matrix,
so my first question is
are you gonna be discussing that tomorrow
and if you're not, could you
briefly discuss it today?
My second question is you seem
to be a very optimistic fellow--
- So sorry?
- [Man] You seem to be
a very optimistic fellow
and the rapid evolution
of cosmological knowledge
over the last 100 years has
indeed been a model of optimism
and the progress of knowledge.
Does the cosmological
community feel a dampening
of that optimism with the onflux
of information regarding
the possible termination
of civilization due to global warming?
So I have a technical
and a sociological question, thank you.
I will not discuss inflation
or brane collisions as models
for what happened before
the universe was expanding,
described by the theory I've mentioned.
That's for another set of lectures,
and what is more, it is
pretty controversial.
These are new ideas and new
ideas always are speculative,
controversial, to be checked.
The checks are not yet in
to the extent that we have
for the idea of the universe
is expanding and cooling.
On that point, I was until recently
a pretty pessimistic fellow.
I was skeptical that we had
all of the pieces in place
but I'm gonna describe
tomorrow why I was driven
to accept that we do
understand an outline,
what the universe has been doing
since it was dense and hot.
As for the future, well, I
hope we will devote resources
to saving this island universe
we live on, the Planet Earth.
I hope we'll also devote a little time
to curiosity and continue to study
the large-scale nature of the universe.
It has lots of secrets to show us still.
I am very optimistic about the prospects
for future research in pure science.
I'm optimistic about the
payoff of some aspects
to be determined of pure
research in better civilization,
if only we'll pay attention.
Am I optimistic about the human race?
Well, I don't know.
(audience laughs)
- Please join me in
thanking Professor Peebles
for a very interesting presentation.
(audience applauds)
(bright synth music)